توتر كبير خلفه الصراع في مضيق تايوان
الذي تحول لساحه حرب غير مباشره بين بكين
وواشنطن الصين تعتبر المضيق جزءا من
منطقتها الاقتصاديه ولا تعترف باستقلال
التايوان اما امريكا فتقول بان الجزء
الاكبر من المضيق يشكل مياها دوليه المضيق
عرف سابقا باسم مضيق فورموزا وهو يفصل بين
ساحل الصين وجزيره تايوان لا يتعدى طوله
180 كيلومترا كما ان اضيق جزء من هذا
المضيق يبلغ اتساعه 130 كيلومترا تقريبا
كل هذه الاجزاء تشكل حدا فاصلا بين مقاطعه
شرقي الصين
تايوان التي يبلغ عدد سكانها اربعه وعشرين
مليون نسمه التوتر المستمر منذ فتره طويله
في هذا المضي ما في وضع خط وسط يقع في
منتصف مضيق تايوان والذي تم وضعه في عام
1955 خط لا تعترف به بكين حيث يمثل حدودا
تقول تايوان بانها نطاق حدودها البحريه
وما بداخله يمثل مياهها الاقليميه وكل
تحرك للصين داخله يعد مساسا بسيادتها
وبعيدا عن جو التوترات يتمتع بضيق تايوان
باهميه تجاريه واقتصاديه كبيره فهو يعتبر
احد اهم الممرات المائيه في العالم
باعتباره قناه شحن دوليه رئيسيه يمر ما
يقرب من نصف حاويه العالم عبره ويعتبر
ايضا طريقا رئيسيا للسفن القديمه من اكبر
الدول المصنعه في اسيا كاليابان والصين
وكوريا الجنوبيه نحو نصف العالم الغربي
حيث ان
88% من اكبر السفن في العالم من حيث
حمولتها مرت عبر هذا المضيق خلال عام
2022 وفقا لبيانات جمعتها وكاله بلومبرج